розмови про Контрнаступ ЗСУ розпочалися
у середині липня Коли Володимир
Зеленський офіційно поставив завдання де
окупувати південь України 29 серпня
українські ЗМІ почали цитувати
спікеркуоперативного командування
південь Наталю Гуменюк щодо наступу ЗСУ
за низкою напрямків на півдні країни
зокрема в Херсонській області Після
багатотижневої фази фактично позиційної
війни без істотних змін на лінії фронту
ця новина розлетілися настільки щорадник
голови офісу президента України Михайло
Подоляк закликав публічних осіб не
робити супер сенсаційних заяв Наталія
Гуменюк також попросила дотримуватися
спокою будь-яка військова операція
потребує умов тиші і те що такий ажиотаж
викликає будь-яка новина з фронту це
насправді дуже неправильно наразі в
умовах гібридної війни новина Є вона
всіх надихнула і так далі Треба
набратися терпіння у Вечірньому зведенні
генштабу ЗСУ про наступ нічого не
повідомили натомість Міноборони Росії
відзвітувало про те що ЗСУ у понеділок
зробили спробу наступу в Миколаївській
та Херсонській областях на трьох
напрямках І що ця спроба цитата з
тріском провалилася у Вечірньому
зверненні Володимир Зеленський повідомив
що провів серію нарад із представниками
армії військово-промислового сектору та
уряду проте не розкрив подробиці щодо
зустрічей хтось хоче знати які у нас
плани ви не почуєте конкретики від
жодної дійсно відповідальної особи бо це
війна і так на війні але окупанти мають
знати ми будемо їх гнати до кордону до
нашого кордону лінія якого не змінюється
окупанти її добре знають якщо вони
хочуть вижити російським військовим
Настав час тікати їдьте додому
Якщо Ви боїтесь повертатись до себе
додому в росі що ж Хай такі окупанти
здаються в полон ми гарантуємо їм
виконання усіх норм женевських конвенцій
з 29 серпня мешканці Херсона почали
публікувати відео зі звуками стрілянини
та вибухами у зведенні британської
розвідки було вказано
зранку 29 серпня 2022 року кілька бригад
ЗСУ посилили артилерійський обстріл на
ділянках фронту на півдні України
Українські далекобійні високоточні удари
продовжили перешкоджати поповненню
російських військ наразі неможливо
підтвердити результати українських
успіхів західні військові експерти
опитані ДВ кажуть що те що зараз
відбувається на південному напрямку
цілком може бути Контрнаступ
Я думаю що Київ перебуває під тиском щоб
армія не просто стояла в обороні а
проводила в наступ Це звісно зрозуміло З
огляду на ті жахливі страждання які
переживає народ України Вони хоробро
борються до того ж Київ отримав мільярди
доларів допомоги тільки від Сполучених
Штатів з січня 21 року 13 з половиною
мільярдів доларів і українці
використовували цю зброю за призначенням
в деяких місцях я не хочу перебільшувати
але вони почали трохи приходити в
Контрнаступ на півдні в районі Херсона і
це з урахуванням того що росіяни
перегрупувалися та передислокували туди
свої війська
ситуація на фронті досі не зрозуміла як
це зазвичай буває під час боїв але гадаю
можна сказати що ця наступальна операція
виглядає масштабнішою схоже вона справді
відповідає тому чого хотів Український
президент Україна мала план досягти
певних успіхів у Херсоні до того як
Росія зможе провести там будь-який
референдум у вересні тож Україна мала
політичні завдання та терміни щоб
досягти своїх цілей у регіоні схоже Все
йде відповідно до цього плану і звичайно
масштаб того що розгортається зараз
набагато більше ніж те що ми бачили
раніше екскомандувач
сухопутних
зазначає що українське командування
ретельно годувалося до наступу замість
того щоб один бій швидкості
українські генштаб добре підготувався
вони почалися необхідності виштовхати
кожен новий танк і кожного нового
солдата на поле бою натомість
розраховували на них щоб сформувати сили
які були б готові розпочати атаку коли
складуться належні умови Тож ми бачимо
наприклад ізоляцію тисяч російських
військ на північно-західному березі
річки Дніпро а також значне скорочення
артилерії з боку Росії усе це є
необхідною підготовкою Я думаю що
Україна якщо справді почне наступ та
обере правильний час і місце для цього в
останні тижні українська армія активно
використовувала надану заходом військову
техніку зокрема для руйнування мостів
навколо Херсона щоб відрізати російські
війська на правому березі де знаходиться
Херсон світлологістики На цьому етапі
Західна зброя на думку результаті
накрампа відіграє чи не вирішальну роль
українці накопичили певну кількість
військової техніки яку їм передали і на
тих небагатьох кадрах які у нас є ми
бачимо деякі збороне-транспортерів
надіслані заходом загалом це виглядає як
цілком значущий загальновійськовий
наступ з використанням танків піхоти
літаків гелікоптерів та артилерії щоб
досягти хоча б обмеженого прориву лінії
фронту з Росією за словами Бена ходжиса
реакція в Росії на поточну ситуацію
різниця від замовчування їх норування до
відкритої паніки
Річ у тім що росіяни ще не вирішили
багатьох проблем які вони мали Які
демонстрували ще в лютому та березні
особливо їхні системи командування та
контролю щодо того як вони ухвалюють
рішення щодо переміщення людей це все ще
Гармидер якщо бути відвертим їхня
логістична система крихка виснажена з
кожним тижнем вона слабша тому вони не
так здатні реагувати на зміни в ситуації
як ми могли очікувати раніше
також підкреслює той факт що російська
армія перебуває у шоковому стані від
попередніх шести місяців війни
в армії проблеми з набором
військовослужбовців втрати танків
вимірюється чотиризначними числами вони
не змогли взяти під контроль повітряний
простір хоча від них чекали Цього вже з
другого дня війни загалом ця армія
прибуває у стані глибокого шоку але
водночас вона неповалена але від такої
великої армії такої потужної країни
нічого іншого і чекати не варто однак
найголовніше те що ця армія виявилася не
в змозі Ані блискавично Ані за півроку
окупувати країну Хоча багато хто вважав
її здатною на це і сам факт того що
амбітні плани Росії провалилися підриває
Віру цієї армії у саму себе робить
висновок німецький експерт